la crise actuelle est très dur à vivre
en fait la crise dure depuis six ans
pour nous éleveurs de porcs alors qu'on
en parle aujourd'hui donc
il ya quelques petites périodes un peu
mieux notamment au moment de l'été au
nom des barbecues mai
le problème de fond n'est pas réglé
c'est à dire que la rentabilité des
élevages n'est pas assurée
par des coûts de production trop
important et les prix de vente de nos
ports trop faible financièrement
la crise porcine ne représente un manque
à gagner de 10 euros
par kilo de partido de cochon kw à 10
euros par porc je veux dire ce qu'il
fait sur 4000 port 40000 euros à l'année
donc c'est un seul revenu que je n'ai
pas eu cette année